so then you know it's doing something that's what i need to know okay the unicorn unicorn
unicode kelvin so dang it guys do not make a meme in freaking discord about unicorn
please i see a t-shirt dude shut up right
that's part of hacking when you can just you know critical thing right
all right hackers here's the deal before you skip forward give me like two seconds to give you a
takeaway okay here it is threat lock or detect is the best edr around they have a ton of tool
integrations the alerts are high signal so you're not swimming in a bunch of garbage and both alerting
and remediation actions are super customizable it's definitely the one you want okay that's it
skip forward if you must but i do feel like you should know why i think that right well we've talked
a lot about the threat locker suite and frankly they're the best implemented tools around from
a technical perspective with the cdr they're focusing a lot on customization and high signal
stuff like powershell activity log deletion sketchy rdp sessions stuff that i have
wished many times edrs were not uh detecting actively okay um and while it does work out of
the box it also gives you the experienced purple teamer the tools you need to implement custom logic to
lock hackers out of your network at the first sign of trouble that trouble is the trouble that you are
the most qualified to recognize so they're equipping you to deal with it right away
um they're definitely the ones you guys want to go with if you're looking for a new edr tool all right
that's it let's go back to the show all right ryan dude come here man thank you so much for today
we've i just had a fantastic day up in reston with ryan barnett um and we're here at the akamai offices
after battling our computer systems for a while to try to get the recording equipment in place
finally able to record the episode um ryan dude i'm looking at this doc you prepped a lot i so
appreciate that well yeah you know i listened to the pod as you well know and i love all the stories
especially war stories and all that stuff and so once you told me the dates i was like okay i got time
let me go through the files here and stuff i thought would be interesting for everybody and
you know us to talk about dude i'm very excited i think it's going to be a new kind of episode you
know a lot of times we have people that are actively hunting in the bug bani scene and you are on the
receiving side of a lot of these reports right and and you see them what's coming through the akamai
bug bounty queue and then you also see the traffic that's happening um live in the akamai network so um
very exciting stuff but before we get into too much of the details you got to cut your teeth with the
bounty with with uh with a bug that you found okay yeah um and and we do have a little bit of a twist
on this for for you today because there's a bug that you found here but there's also a couple bugs
that you've triaged that you were excited about so yeah um let's uh let's do a proof of concept here
let's uh poc or gtfo and uh tell me tell me what you got um so the first one was interesting um
because it was actually an accidental finding which sometimes that happens right you're using an app yeah so
this was a number of years ago but i was using uh online uh blogging software type pad i'm in the
middle of talking about some research right on cross-site scripting i'm typing up so i'm in the
editor and out of nowhere it popped up redirected to a third-party website oh man and of course my
spidey sense is like oh wait what's going on refresh doing it again happens again then i stopped and i
looked at where it was redirecting me to and i said whoa whoa whoa this was from a blog post i did a
week ago i said wait a second so the short of this is i had to get out some tools to look at what
was going on and see where my traffic was going so what happened was a week before i did a blog post
talking about cross-site scripting and there were cross-site scripting tags that were in uh user agent
headers so i'm putting it into the blog and when i put it in the blog i made sure the html entity and
code of course as you would yeah i did everything by the book and so uh the problem was what was
interesting once i tracked this down was in type pad they have all these plugins and what they want to
do is as you're typing as an editor it would show you oh we see the content you're doing here are some
related posts if you want to cross-link okay so it cross-linked with one of my former posts well what
happens is this third party and it's fixed so obviously so i can say it was called zamanta they had
uh api clients they come and scrape your content when they scraped it it was the rendered content so as
i'm typing and they said oh we have a suggestion here it comes back in json non html entity encoded and then
the other key piece was the plugin when it got that json it wrapped it it treated it as html
so popped and i was like ah crap so two things number one vulnerability disclosure i worked with
them they fixed it i guess that's one advantage of the kind of sas platforms that they don't have to
give patches to people they just fixed it boom done cross the board yeah treat it as text it was fixed
but for me that day forward i do pictures of exploit code i don't do text you never know there can be an
api and today it's like even worse right with all these api ai agents crawling and you don't know what
they're doing with your data or how they make i mean even with pictures nowadays sometimes something
will ocr it you know and they're like that's true but uh but yeah i mean i i definitely i think that's
definitely the safest way to go but then me for me when i'm trying to hack something right on the other
side of the board i'm like oh let me copy this no it's a picture yeah i'm like yeah geez it's it's a
balance it is but that showed me it's like you don't know who's coming to grab that content so that
was very tricky absolutely man and i think one of the unique things that we've discussed time and time
again is like how much you see the way that the internet is connected internet is connected from
across all of these different you know pieces right you know somebody puts in a piece of data here and
somehow it ends up you know in your client's log somehow and it's causing a problem somewhere right yeah
um all the the blind stuff yeah you put it in it'll pop out i can't imagine how many websites have alert
one you know just like popping up on the back end you know and they're like oh that's kind of funky but
nobody like took the time to do a blind xss payload or something like that yeah well tons of our
customers with sims and looking at logs yeah yeah yeah that's uh yeah custom stuff in the sims as well
you know it can it can pop anywhere um okay so you got you got chat scatter and you got abusing
third-party analytics yeah where are we going um well we can cover both they're fast again so these were
ones like triaged so cross-site scripting problem uh once it comes through um you know whoever's doing
the bug bounty program who's our customer back to us so these two different ones uh one looking at
it was um abusing some javascript analytic code okay so this fits in with all the printers that you
got to look and say okay what are all these urls javascript's calling up look at these endpoints
what are they doing and here was actually looking through the code because what they figured out was
um there was a function in the javascript that was pulled up where it was talking about a mod
configuration override set to true oh geez so the attacker just puts it in a query string so instead
of passing in javascript past it in a query string and then it's this long kind of serialized uh
configuration to say oh turn it on and by the way here's a script which is my hacker script which pulled
it up but like from our perspective those aren't normal payloads that we see yeah so it's really
abusing that default config yeah uh the short one there is of course we help the customer to tell
them what was going on you know we updated their configs um but the vendor silently fixed it
of course classic you're back to the sas platform though they just went and tweaked it
um so that's where wayback saves you of course because i can't go back and say this is what it was
right it was like this it was like this um and then the last one uh called chat scatter um again working
with the customer um there was some cross-site scripting stuff coming in once i was kind of
triaging looking at it cross-site scripting coming in a certain query string parameter but the parameter
was an entire long payload it was a uri from not our customer site third-party site so i had to start
tracing it back so you go to what that other site was and looking through and then time to tie back how
does this relate to our customer it was a chat widget so you get to that page hey papa can we help
you we want to talk to you so what's interesting those are everywhere nowadays yeah everything yeah
they pop up but so again for bug hunters knowing what happens there as soon as you load that in your
browser it can be making back in api calls and what it was doing is grabbing the entire uri and beaconing
to our customer so what i was seeing was telemetry this backscatter or chat scatter of bug hunters and
real attackers attacking cross-site scripting and it immediately sends it off to us and we see it so
they're not attacking our customer but we saw so for me interesting conversation sorry our customer smack the
mic yeah i do it all the time man uh with our customer to say look you do not have a vulnerability
your customer is using your software being attacked and i did confirm some of the cross-site scripting
that worked yeah and i said you might want to tell them yeah but there's an interesting situation
these are smaller companies who don't have security teams and they can misinterpret and say well this is
because of your software so it was up to them i don't know who all they reached out to but right
you know to get pass on the information as a good net citizen and say you may want to tell those well
i think it's something you know you see a lot of client-side stuff by nature of what you're doing
there and i think that analytics um those analytics uh providers you know they're integrated and sometimes
you go into some of these sites and they've got like 10 of them right and some of the the ones that
are i mean not to say that there isn't a vulnerability out there and like google tag manager
something i'm sure there is somebody can find not me um but you know in some of these other sketchy
analytics plugins there are a lot of weird configuration overrides why are you parsing
this url parameter you know like um i'll never forget i was at a live hacking event and there was this
piece of scope that everybody struggled with because there just wasn't very much there right they're
like there's not a lot of functionality we can't really do anything and somebody ended up finding like
a beautiful dom xss that affected every single page of that site because of this weird analytics
thing that they found and uh it was just taking a url parameter and in like you said importing a javascript
file so yeah um yeah they're they're out there they exist and it's it's a challenge because that's
usually a totally different team than the app team and they're kind of forcing in certain analytics
stuff for business yeah for marketing analytics yeah yeah absolutely it's and they probably don't
necessarily go through the same vendor vetting as like some of the other um places do and and actually
come to think about i think i've mentioned this on the pod a couple times but um i'm thinking about
a specific target where um you know is a very high security target that has to be by nature of their
industry um and yeah you know we spent so much time poking at the client side of this thing and then of
course the hole is in the third-party software that they just kind of threw in there as like let me
add this chatbot let me add this analytics right yeah um and we ended up hopping a bunch of loans
because of that vulnerable analytics uh piece yeah and for crazy man other folks you've had on the
show yeah you're just talking about lupin yeah like supply chain that's all this stuff and they're
adding stuff in yeah yeah different vectors yeah lots of different stuff there okay so the meat of
okay let me let me back up i always i always get tempted you know because we get in the in the vibe
from the the volantalk yeah i always forget to come back to the introduction and then when i do my
dad always messages me and he's like joshin you forgot to introduce and i'm like why are you watching
this 20 minutes in anyway dad you don't understand anything that's happening but shout out to dad thank
you for watching episodes and keeping me um uh in line with that um so with that i'll back up guys
this is ryan barnett he's uh an og in the defender space and actually we found out recently that i
bought your book back in 2017 when i was first learning how to hack i was like oh i got to get this
you know application defenders cookbook right and uh or and you know try to like figure out exactly what
i'm up against here right um and i went to my amazon history and it bought in 2017 i was like no way
that's my boy ryan perfect um so thank you for the the content you put out um really appreciate that
and um yeah i mean your your track record speaks for speaks for itself you're at mod security you're
at uh akamai now as a as a principal researcher for like 10 years a decade wow dude and and and we
were at lunch before this we went out and grabbed lunch before and i was just telling him like that's
inspiring because you know so many you know we really value highly technical people here on the podcast and
um you know so many people especially in a you know bigger company where it would be easy
to go up the up the ladder a little bit you know yeah uh it takes a lot of grit to stick to uh you
know uh you know well it's our research position it is it's a passion i love research and you you did
you did a lot of it for a long time thank you we're also joking about persistence yeah both for bug
hunters and also on the defensive side persistence is key yeah absolutely man well um you know obviously you're
working with akamai um the gut feeling when we hear the word akamai is terror you know from the from the
bug bounty hunter like ah that i just get my whole ip burned again like why can't i get my cross-site
scripting payload through um so i think you know one of the things we had here in in the doc as far as
discussion goes is this bug bounty versus waaf like how do we balance these two things in the industry and you know
know sometimes it is like we're juxtaposed you know it's like we're it's like we're up against each
other here you know um but we often forget that we're all on the same team so um i guess what what
are some things you want hackers to know about that that dynamic um of you know we're aspect as bug
bounty hunters we're on the same team but we're going up against you guys all the time yeah so a couple
different kind of discussion points and we can take different angles um one of the main one we always
start with is our customers and particularly when they're working in bug bounty it's like what what is
their main goal now everybody intuitively jumps to well defined bones that's why you do bug bounty
which it is but it's not every use case or some start there and they move to a different use case so
you can look at it as vulnerability enumeration if that's their main goal then they want bug hunters
to find the bugs so then if we're in the middle there how do they want us to treat the traffic
right so part of that is just understanding what the customers want and what their goal is
so in that scenario if that's their goal we need to figure out ways to allow bug hunters to get by
what we're doing just yeah olay let you through so there's ways they can do that for commercial
scanning companies right okay okay i like where this is going ryan okay yeah yes uh but that's because
they have registered ip space right right so it's like oh your qualus your white hat your verica your
whoever um we know your ips and it's easy in the product to do a bypass list if you're coming from
this trusted space okay you can get through sure um as everybody knows who's listening to this
you can't use your ip right that's ephemeral yeah and you sometimes have to hop and go around so
there's really not a good mechanism to let somebody go through if they wanted to yeah now the other
category is that we have of customers are it's not just about finding bones it is but there's a matter
of exploit tivity of it like we have to prove that you can get to this and that's where they want to
act like normal and treat bug hunters like they would anybody else and do whatever you're going to do
lock that request mess with the ip dude like do whatever um it's very interesting we had conversations
with some of these customers to understand like oh okay that's interesting uh but they want to do
attacker simulation yeah and they want it to be as as real world you know right and yeah it's a balance
because then they can prove this is exploitable and there's an issue with the waft blocking it
because if they get to that there's waft bypass yeah so it's a matter of them figuring out priority
because they may have a list of things that they found internally you know sast and all these other
things and they're like okay we have this pile of things we have to fix which ones we do first
oh waft's helping us with some coverage here let's delay that other leak or so but if you prove bug
hunters can get to it bypass off here oh crap real threat actors can do that now we have to bump you
up the suddenly becomes and and i mean that's what all of security is right there's always improvements
that need to be made somewhere in the system right you know and so that's a good point you know if you
are able to bypass the waft uh it helps with the whole triaging of issues right and triage in a
different sense you know figure assigning the the severity and the priority of these of these you know
various things you need to address in your security program right um dude i just i hate it a little
bit though like like come on like you know i can bypass this ryan i can't i just i'm spending so
much time yeah you know like there's a number of things too that we talked about there on from an
external perspective people see waft that are really a lot of separate products tied together we have
things that look for just how fast people are going and the customers can figure out those are rate
controls yeah they're going too familiar with that one yeah exactly and you can get blocked for a while
then there's client reputation and that's the biggest thorn for the bug hunters yes it is because
it's a little it's more persistent um it doesn't have to be just the website you're interacting with
where you were bug hunting because now akamai is giving that ip a global score and then other
people who have client reputation can choose to use that score it's not waft blocking you it's waft saying
hey here's the score and then the customer can choose what they want to do and some people want
to get aggressive and say do you've attacked another customer i don't want you to attack me and
we block you there yeah yeah dude it's that's a pain and that's what uh there's always like um there's
like a little meme that goes around in the bug bunny community of like oh you know you're hacking
you're hacking all of a sudden you know your wife in the other room is like justin why can't i get on
you know whatever website i'm like i can't shop like dang it what did i do yeah uh yeah yeah so
that's an issue it is it is and and i think there's but i mean like you said there's the
there's two sides of this of the same coin right you know we do want to try to show what is
actually exploitable live you know and at the end of the at the end of the day i think that's probably
the thing that aligns best with the bug bounty methodology right the poc or gtfo world right um
but man it would be nice to get get around it sometimes and and you asked me an interesting
question over lunch you said hey justin would you would you rather have some way to bypass akamai
right and like say we did like some uh you know certificate based authentication and we were able
to get you know trusted testers past akamai right uh and take a lower bounty or or would you rather
just poc or gtfo it and i'm like oh what's option c yeah exactly right yeah but the reason why that
comes up again a lot of bug hunters maybe don't have the same conversations we do with our customers
yeah and it's for them to understand it was that second category we talked about that if they're doing
threat actor simulation um as not not the primary it's always about bones yeah but that aspect they
may be um setting their bounties in accordance with that that it is raising your cost you know yeah
there's a chance for a dupe yeah you gotta go through different vps like you have to do extra work
but you're getting this amount so yeah i don't know that's a a question for every hunter to have to
decide for themselves it's painful number one oh no it's painful man and and i do like the way you've
broken it down here i'll just repeat this back for the listener you know um there there are two two
organ two types of organizations really one that prioritize vulnerability enumeration right that's
you know bug bounty hunters being able to say hey there is a vulnerability here but the waaf is
just a thorn in my side you know if i spend two hours i can bypass it but you'd rather me spend time
enumerating other vulnerabilities right that sort of organization would prioritize that sort of
behavior and then there's the prevention of exploitation attempts right uh types of
organizations where they really just want poc or gtfo and let me you know assign severity and
triage these issues so it's it's a very interesting um you know description of the industry that you've
set up and i think it's very accurate yeah um very cool man uh there's a lot of things that i i
would love to i'd love to get to here so i think the next one that we'll hop into is this whole concept of
of virtual patching right um where the waaf is being used to wall off specific endpoints as as zero days
you know come out and and sometimes it's a it's something that will solve the problem sometimes
there's you know ways you can path traverse around it and stuff like that um yeah how much of this how
much of this is your main focus at akamai like in and how have you seen customers implement this
effectively um yeah so two levels the the real key here virtual patching as a term sometimes people
really don't like oh really and i enter yeah and i understand why and really this falls in the same
bucket we always everybody talks about if an organization is deciding not to actually fix code
and do anything else you're like yeah you're sure yeah so a virtual patch some people can misconstrue oh
it's patched it's like no that the code's not passed and so one other should rebrand it temporary
virtual patch you know like yeah but that's a key thing it should be temporary yeah give you time to
fix the code right um so anyways the key here is how wafts typically work out of the box
as attack detection systems they look for bad stuff coming in right and another thing thinking about
coming on the pod talking with you and thinking about meta discussions like uh wafts live in a sources
world bug hunters live in a sinks world yeah right and that is a good that is a good line ryan that
is a good let's put that in a short put that in a short team yeah it's true because they're different
views they're all part of the process um and so we're looking at data coming in attacks another way i
talk like in the industry with our customers they're used to like mitre and cwe discussions last we live
in a kpec discussion and you know you have to make those correlations so here think of waft as a tool
really the paradigm changes is once a vulnerability is known like when traffic's just going and people
put a laugh in front and we have our default stuff there sure we can see a lot of bad stuff in whack-a-mole
we don't know if where when there's a bone now if they can signal to us oh we know there's a bone
here because we get a bug family report they do pen tests they do code review then think of laugh as
a tool to implement some sort of mitigation to you know reduce risk right um the other one we talked
about is like uh sharepoint stuff that just comes out exactly it's the same discussion it's just we
didn't get that from a customer we got it from microsoft third party but oh vulnerability
intelligence custom logic quasi virtual patch the the key here too like you were saying how good is it
to do that and how long like what's the half-life yeah of a virtual patch is how you're choosing what
logic to put in still if you're still trying to negative security stuff it's not as good it's tricky
though to figure out what should the payload be like we'd love to do positive security we don't know
the app necessarily so it's key on the vulnerability details to really figure out how to do that yeah
yeah two two directions i'd like to go with that one i want to go back to the the sources and sinks
world so we'll we'll um we'll circle back around to that but you know staying on topic of virtual
patching there are scenarios though when you're standing up a third-party software and that third
party software doesn't have you know you don't have the ability to patch that live you know and and you
know you can put akamai in front of it and wall off certain endpoints but then you know that's pretty
much the extent of what you can do until the vendor patches right and then you know this this is kind of
where these virtual patches become a little bit more of a permanent solution right if you cannot get that
that software to to patch um so there's been a couple vulnerabilities that i've found in the past where
you know people are abusing um the waft to just see like okay well you can't access slash debug anymore
you know but but really you know there's path reversals there's um other ways of accessing those
endpoints maybe method overrides or whatever um or path overrides uh that you can utilize to get at
them so it's a tricky balance between that right yeah it's another thing we talked about maybe we'll
loop back to it it's the whole hacking resistance discussion yeah because this is a really good point yeah
whatever security logic you're putting in i'm gonna grab my notebook really quick keep going yeah yeah
you know whatever security logic you're putting in it's a question of like how strong is that against
what type of attacks to do evasions right to get around it like you were mentioning um a lot of these
two depend on what's the category of the problem um sometimes there's discussions oh we found this problem
and quote unquote is this laughable like can we do something that's like that's more of an auth problem
you know access control off like those are things that when you have a third party system
we don't have the knowledge or the insights and to know exactly what should be done there right so
it's not that a waf can fix everything but some stuff would fit in there nice yeah uh so yeah hacking
resistance it's like okay we think that this would hold up but if you have a persistent yeah attacker that's
banging banging banging banging who knows how long that this can hold up right and it's a good way to
simulate that in the bug bounty world right like you know we we are persistent because we're motivated
actors you know because we're getting motivation from the money and and you know just like apts are
getting motivation from whatever they're getting motivation from so i think it is a i think it is a cool
a cool simulation and and um definitely there's this world in which having a laugh in front of your assets
makes you that much more annoying to hack where the where the hacker will just go hack something that's
less annoying tack you know um potentially whether it's real threat actors that like you said oh here's
the new cve of the day yeah i don't care if it's this company or that company you know i just want to
upload my web shell exactly they'll just move on you're you're weeding out all your botnet you know
your ransomware actors there's a lot of noise yeah you can just yeah yeah that's good um swinging back
around to your quote saying that you know laughs live in the source world and hackers kind of live in
the sync world or at least the connection world between the two um i think that's super pivotal for
uh bug bounty hunters to understand and now we get to do this segment ryan where i'm not sure how this
is going to be for you as an akamai employee but um i kind of wanted to talk about what seems to me
to be an unfixable problem in the waf world which is that um you don't know you know what's going to
happen on the on the flip side of your waf right on on the back end and so um you know you're you have
to make assumptions that that especially in the xss world makes it very very hard especially if you're
doing context aware yeah um you know uh blocking it makes it very difficult for a waf to perform
properly so the example that i that i'll often give is this let's say i've got an image tag image
tags need to be able to flow through the waf as a part of like you know user supplied input um you know
it's very common um and and maybe you know like an attribute a non-malicious attribute such as x
is also allowed right and so let's say you do something like this x equals double quote right
and then you do percent 22 and x equals double quote percent 22 you're inside of the html attribute
context right yeah um and then you know you can put anything inside of that x attribute and it's not
going to be malicious right um but so so the you know the the waf thinks okay you know now we're inside
of this x attribute so if i have something you know slash on error equals alert one right and then double
quote again right that's all just a part of the x attribute but really the back end is decoding that
percent 22 or the percent 25 22. right and and the the miss and sometimes it's it's inverse right
sometimes the waf will be smart about it and say okay well i know that that percent 22 is also a double
quote so i'm gonna decode that well then you can flip it on its head you know and and say
okay well now you think that i'm not in an attribute but i am in an attribute right and so and so there's
lots of ways that you can sort of flip that on its head um and i know you've seen that problem before
like just just yesterday yeah and i'm not kidding yeah oh geez um i mean is there is there some sort
of solution to this uh or is this just something that you guys are going to have to continue playing a
whack-a-mole game with um a combination yeah of it um getting back to the whole whack-a-mole and how
we were joking before where it's like okay i've been doing laugh now 20 years yeah oh geez too long
and at black hat i can't remember uh 2011 i gave a talk called cross-site scripting street fight
dude and you can find it i think it'll probably be in show notes i think it's in our thing yeah so the
idea was going through all these stages of waft what do i try and do let me try this but then the bug
hunter attacker does this crap that doesn't work let me try this here's the evasion for that and it's the
chess game back and forth back and forth regular so there's always blacklisting whack-a-mole approach
because you can do that the question is how much coverage are you getting right yeah and then these
evasions um ultimately where i am today personally understanding the limits because we live in a source
world and what we're looking at the big x factor for us or or what i want to say uh challenges are
the black box behind us and it's not just the customer app if you think about what we what we're
tasked with right i'm sorry as as defenders of it can be going to some application tier
esp java like whatever can do all sorts of decodings potentially it could go into databases they
may do something and then something different when they pull it out to use it but then also what
you just said think about browsers and then we have to do that layer as well so a common thing that with
the researchers i work with and we talk about this and uh there's also a funny situation again this
kind of cross-pollination of of us attackers and defenders we hire a lot of bug hunters yeah on the
team and yeah exactly and we kind of joke when they come in we said look we brought you because it's
the whole kind of know your enemy so to speak and how to attack but then i always throw out the uh star
wars yoda line i said you must unlearn what you have learned and so ryan dude i gotta i gotta work
with you man like this is like amazing whoever gets that job i'm jealous of you to work with ryan so
what we're thinking about here and this is a common phrase that we have to use is can we as akamai do
customizations for your snowflake app because you want us to help you protect it absolutely outside of
that it's best size fits most we have to figure out okay what can we do that will work across every
single company customer and scale and so a lot of times what you get into is between the app tier
database web browser or whatever who's going to decode what is it going to decode once twice three
times mutations yeah it's the issue we saw yesterday yeah data came in a bunch of stuff was encoded
up to three times in certain parts but then by the time it made it into the sink
the thing that was decoded three times was fully decoded other stuff was not touched wasn't even decoded
one so we're in a very tough position to match up decoding so yeah it's a constant battle uh to figure
out how much to do how much not to do and you just have to tackle it from different angles of detection
yeah absolutely and and one of the and i just wanted to mention this for the listener because i i kind of
sort of said a lot of code a second ago was one of the interesting things about html attributes is
if you if you start an html attribute with a double quote obviously that double quote becomes the
encapsulating you know right piece for that html attribute but if you start the double quote with
the the actual text percent 22 then there's no there's no encapsulating attribute right and you can
you know a space will terminate that ht html attribute so so i you know the there's so many
tricks you can do where it's like okay we're gonna put a double quote at the beginning of this a this
attribute right right uh encoded as percent 22 and the waaf has to think okay well i think that's a
double quote which makes this this a quoted html attribute right but actually if they're not decoding
it then it's not a quoted it's an unquoted and there's different terminators right so it's like
there's there's so many layers to that um and it's it's a very tricky very tricky problem yeah
definitely another key thing i would say is well it depends it always depends on the exact context yeah
um some other phrases i've used in the past which i think are relevant here yeah we're in a world of
artificial intelligence i go old school again for those people who know marcus rainham from a long
time ago he had artificial ignorance and it's a totally different approach because when you know
certain things that you already know about you filter those out anything left over so we try and
take multi-approaches to this because it's very hard to get the context right because we're not in the
sinks yeah so we don't really know where it's a hard job you're doing ryan right it's hard man so yeah
all i can say is multi-dimensional detections of ways to try and detect this because you try and do
certain things in context if that doesn't work you take a step back and you look more general and you
catch a lot of those that get by the other one so let me ask you this you know this this situation that
i described with like hgm attributes that is something that um affects context aware laughs right right and
i'm wondering you know how far you can get in your opinion with just like you know regexes or like you
know blacklists or or really you know at the end of the day it's going to be very hard if you to get
anything through if you're allowing or to to prevent everything from getting through if you're allowing
less than and a you know uh an alphabet character right yeah um that's kind of where it kind of
reduces down to i think in a big way yeah so maybe there's a regex for that you know regex serves a
purpose yeah and i i'm forgetting off the top of my head chomsky whatever model that's like you have regex
we have a higher level grammar we can't define yeah that higher level with so regex serves a purpose but
we realize the limitations but yeah it serves a purpose because it's fast you know you can iterate
and do stuff quickly but we have other ways to to look at that data it going back to what you were
saying especially on client side yeah yeah um i did some things in the past i think we had talked about
mod security we had these cross-site scripting challenges where and i said it in the cross-site scripting
street fight presentation that's like this is a browser problem it's like yeah the app's not
properly encoding or output you know encoding escaping data but ultimately the problem is in
the browser so there are situations for example and this is i think there's some stuff in the in the
dock where some of our customers really want to get into things like content security policy or
pushing something like uh don't purify yeah we can do that from the edge we can dynamically modify data on
the way out because we have separate products that do different things and we can dynamically put down
purify so there's all sorts of other things because i'm like look like you said there's a limit to what
you can do with sources so for our customers that want to get more advanced say okay we can help you
and dynamically put that in um so i don't know it's like more it's a question of what is wow
and where does it end what is wow yeah i love that well it it goes to what you are going to talk
about in a minute as well here with regards to unicode normalization right um this order of operations
right like because if we put dom purify i'm sure you know but if we put dom purify at the edge if
there's any modification of that data post dom purification you know uh then it's it's going to
affect the integrity of the work that dom purify does sure and if you see any you know on encoding or
anything like that then uh dom purify becomes you know it doesn't work effectively so man it is a
hard problem to solve but i think we're going to continue going back and forth as uh as waaf and bug
hunter and uh treating trading punches in the street fight right yes yes or we have to do our own
rescue exactly yeah dude right at the end um i did want to mention one other thing here which is
going to be interesting i think that one of the things i'm most excited about is uh for the onset of
hack bots is a waaf bypassing bot uh i think that's going to be really interesting um and kaido by the
time this uh episode airs or i'm going to have to cut this segment we'll see uh kaido uh will have
released this thing called uh shift agents where you can inside of kaido create your own hack bot of
sorts and and delegate a tab to the task yeah you can give it a task and you can give it a tab in in
replay right okay and then it will modify replay and you can you know click through it just like you
normally do forward forward back back and see what things it's tried and then create things um so what
i wanted to ask about that was like i and i don't know man ryan you can you can sit you can not
answer this i told you i was going to put the screws to you a little bit on this podcast what kind of
things do we need to have in our arsenal as as hackers what should we know about bypassing wafts
um we talked about encoding already is there anything else you can give us oh no uh this may
have to be uh when we're in vegas at a face-to-face get-together uh-huh i don't know that's a good
i'm not sure well i mean most things are out there yeah um no i will say in general and it's not an akamai
thing yeah is joining different i think everybody knows akamai is the biggest pain in the ass to bypass
like it is we hope so it's very hard but go ahead yeah it's when you're joining multiple different
techniques together and you know if you go to like even port swiggers cheat sheet cross-site scripting
it's like they have a lot of individual things but if you start mixing and matching
um that's a challenge um yeah i mean outside of that of course then it's uh secrets we can't
we can't take you behind the the come on right all powerful i know it's in here somewhere what room
where do you keep the wife the laugh bypass that's down the hall i gotta keep an eye on just dang it
my badge gotta have access to that yeah um well very very good man very good um so i guess we talked a
little bit about what it would look like you know how hackers often circumvent wavs um but one of the
things we didn't touch on quite as much is this this piece of ad a aws api gateways and using stuff like
um fireprox and stuff like that you know to get around these ip-based restrictions and i know that you
have mentioned in the past that um aws has this as a part of their terms of service that that we
shouldn't be we shouldn't be using that um
like what what i want you to say to the bug hunter is you know to do it or not to do it right
it kind of goes to this whole this whole concept of like bug bounty is supposed to be an emulation of
attackers and they're not actively preventing us from using uh aws gateway do you think it's it's
unethical for an ethical hacker to do that oh that's a good one um i think it's tough when you
know what the acceptable use policy is yes choose to vote that's a personal decision so what you're
saying we should cut this segment is that what you're saying so speaking in general for a second
like you said there's a couple tools right that can help to automate some of this but part of the
question is okay why are you doing this well it's the ip blocking and so you have to be able to
distribute whatever you want to do workloads yeah and come different ips so you're getting around that
problem so there are ways to do that that don't violate acceptable use um so another interesting side
thing right akamai had purchased linode yeah a few years back ups right they had a lot of bug hunters
on there and a lot of people were using like axion yeah and those kinds of tools yeah uh for a while i
talked to the trust and safety it wasn't my doing and everybody said i'm just i'm on a webex with those
yeah yeah hey we have to cut this because people were running it to the hill oh yeah and it was having
network problems so they disallowed axiom for a little while but their customers will say hey we're
going to go somewhere else we'll go to a different vps so they worked with axiom uh project folks okay
and there is a document there says hey everybody if you're going to run this here's a way to put some
bounds here's a few flags that maybe people didn't know about you can still scan but you won't take
down the network right here's a few flags that you didn't know about clearly read the docs um so there's
ways to do all of that now where it gets interesting again is for me i have to deal with both threat
actors and bug hunters and threat actors are a pain they have dtps that they do bug hunters we've joked
they're they're we have a frenemy relationship yes right we are all security researchers you're not my
enemy but the interesting thing is when the ttps overlap and what i was seeing is we see attack traffic
coming from amazon api gateway ips and the there's a lot of overlapping topics here but how would i know
once i investigate this is a bug hunter right so i can start to look now if the program says you have
to do request header tagging and say hacker one handle i can look and say okay they're bug hunters not
a big deal the problem is we were seeing enough traffic where there were no indications that it was bug
hunter yeah a lot of people don't use those headers yeah and then i said okay they might not use the
headers but then i was looking at what was being sent and it was stuff that was more damaging the
sequel injection dropping tables and i said this could be a regular attacker yeah not bug hunter so
i have to initiate conversations with security teams at aws yeah very similarly we saw on cloudflare
people setting up web workers all they were doing is open proxy and they would funnel their traffic geez
so i had to get with cloudflare even though competitors but there's a security trust safety
so here's where it gets interesting though like you said the the person doing the activity and saying
okay is this acceptable use am i going to get in trouble like all that it's a similar thing for the
companies i talk with because it's a situation of if you're doing this but you're paying your bill every
month right do they really care yeah so i don't know the mileage varies where sometimes they say no no
we're shutting this down and they do other times they don't because you pay for it but one other thing
bug hunters should think about too from a linode perspective yeah the trust and safety team uh sometimes
people will get access spin stuff up scan who are not bug hunters or threat actors and they've
used a stolen credit card yeah and quickly they figure it out and shut it down but they scan for a
day you know what i mean so keep that in mind when you're doing what you're doing as bug hunters
you're you're right next to people who aren't sometimes there's some friendly fire repercussions we are
sorry well i i i like that i like that because it is frustrating you know especially when you're an
ethical researcher it's like no i'm on your team stop inhibiting me but yeah especially when that
infrastructure is also being used negatively and you know you're saying it is um it's a difficult
it's a difficult balance to strike but yeah i think i think if you can use stuff like um like axiom or
shadow clone or whatever right and not break the uh the the terms of service on a lot of these uh
yeah providers then maybe that's maybe that's for the best as much as i hate to say it yeah yeah yeah
what um i guess let me ask you this has there been thought and has akamai sort of pursued working with
the platforms to create an environment where um hackers could either go through a vpn or a proxy or
something like that and bypass the waft to validate their proof of concepts um you know in kind of working
with the platform for that um to a certain degree yes i mean i've we've talked i know offline a little
bit about this but yeah just brainstorming lots of different ways to figure this out as we're saying
the normal mechanisms to allow a commercial desk customer just aren't there in this yeah the ips
are rotating constantly yeah so you need some way to validate if you're coming directly through the waft
product so uh there's some discussions i will say they're early but talking about part of the question
is if you wanted to do something like this who registers the bug hunter who gives a token who
manages there's that question of who could do that but if something's implemented then it's a matter of
akamai making it an option for a customer to opt into if they even wanted to do that yeah but you would
let them buy there so yeah we're brainstorming some ideas because we know it's a pain point there's there's
some there's some stuff in this document here about using like tls fingerprints to try to figure out
i'm trying to think about how all that would work what is what is the vision for that well again
this is me yeah this is just ryan this is a ryan okay brainstorming yeah um and uh i don't think he
would care i said anything but like i pinged uh ben yeah i'm saying hey if we were to do something
like this because the question is how can we validate somebody that's not an id yeah and there's
tools out there that let's say you're going through a proxy that you can run that will funnel all
your traffic goes over then tls different tools where oh wait a second in tls there's all this
different data in there where you can have like a comment field maybe you put your hacker hand like
something there the end result is certain parts of your tls fingerprint will change and all of a sudden
that becomes unique to you and so i'm mentioning that because in akamai's waft product you can do a
bypass list based on a tls signal really yeah okay so we're trying to figure out low friction
yeah how do you make that simple for the researcher and for the companies that are implementing that so
i don't know that we are at brainstorming phase so hopefully they're saying when we're out in vegas and
we're yeah brainstorming with hackers and whatever maybe there's other ideas but any way we can do one
of the other things that i kind of thought of for this was attacking the problem from the application layer
and saying hey okay we've got a set of um certificates that uh trusted researchers have
and then we create our our http request and we you know add an x akamai researcher header with the
signature for the for that request right right and and you know that includes a time stamp and stuff like
that so it can't be like vulnerable to replay attacks right and then we utilize that it it's not going to
be perfect because you know it's not going to get us past all of the like and all of our tools aren't
going to be able to integrate that that signing structure and stuff like that but at least for like
kaido and burp you would be able to have an extension that would um allow you to get past akamai right to
get at the target well most the cdm platforms are able to do client certificate validations so yeah it
makes more sense to do it at the tls layer i think well yeah it just depends on how you wanted to
implement so it is a problem that should be solved we gotta keep brainstorming i guess very tricky
very tricky um so dude you are presenting at black hat this year with your daughter come on give me some
that's like dad goals right there absolutely um congrats isabella on getting your uh talk accepted
that's really awesome congrats to you ryan um you know you you've done some unicode stuff last year
as well um can you give us a teaser of what lost in translation is going to look like this year um
yeah i guess by the time this has aired but it'll already be out so yeah don't give me a teaser give
me give me the good stuff yeah that's very true yeah um yes you'll be able to go i think download
our presentation yeah um yeah so last year at defcon bug bounty village um it was a higher level concept
of what are different ways where back to this order of operation problem if data goes through some
security checks and then later it's changed in some way that causes a problem right so last year we
talked about different scenarios you have like edge site includes that might change it on the way back
out yeah um uh there was the html entity decoding which can split in the end like there's all sorts of
different things so the one that resonated though was things related to unicode yeah so we said okay
that's what was interesting can we expand it a bit so over the past year we were trying to gather
stuff and my daughter i think had laughed at me before like when we're on you know socials or doing
whatever and i said oh bookmark oh bookmark said what are you doing i said anytime i see cool stuff on
our our like feeds i'm like oh bookmark that for later yeah i come back so just to give kind of a
quick run through on on what this is kind of from a agenda perspective um one thing that's interesting
is you have to start with url decoders like before you even get to what the character should be like
in its regular form or glyph or whatever so url decoders can have different problems the first one
is if it is not multi-byte aware which you would think isn't it 20 25 what yeah you think you think
that that would be solved already but really like multi-byte i think a deep understanding of unicode is
pretty is pretty rare and yeah i know i talked to i think you probably listened to the episode with
the ts and where we where we uh talked about this a little bit so you know lately it's been coming
across you know the pod a good bit that these multi-byte sequences can be really um really impactful
yeah so what was interesting as we were going to prep the what do we show people when we're talking
about this well just fire up burp and go to decoder yeah it's not multi-byte aware yeah you put in utf-8
you get mojibake yeah so we had to get a different extension yeah what did you say moji what mojibake
that's what it's called what is mojibake that is when data is translated in a way that it was not
encoded and you get gibberish it's called mojibake ah okay i was gonna say you're picking up on the
japanese yeah yeah i'm like yeah yeah so i said that word uh isabella and same thing she's like wait what is
that so we were researching yeah but it has a name so yeah and burp you have to use decoder improved
it's got java swing line and it under properly decodes yeah it understands utf-8 basically so that's
one thing and there's lots of things that are not fully like say multi-byte aware because technically
we're just saying really utf-8 normally the other one is overlong encoding so so let me ask a question
about that so multi-byte sequences that's when you've got like um percent ef uh percent bc and then
something else right and it's got those those longer sequences that that will create a unicode character
correct okay so a great shout out maybe it'll be in the notes sonar source they do a lot of great
research but they have a tool it's a utf-8 online visualizer yeah it is awesome it's so fun i've seen
that before and we've covered it on the pod and i totally forgot about it and i i was having trouble
visualizing this in the pod with matias and like four people messaged me and were like you should use
this like yeah there it is yeah uh very very cool piece of software they built there yeah and it's
great because it shows you at the bottom the utf-8 encoded bytes yeah the next thing are the actual raw
bytes and then you have the unicode code point and the glyph yeah so it depends on what layer you want
to look at um but it it helps you to understand that wait a second these three individual bytes
that are encoded that's percent eighty percent whatever they're all in relation to each other
because there's one that's a leading byte and then you have a continuation continuation by yeah but it
depends on what the character is and what each byte is storing and things like that but yeah if you
mojibake it and you just get crap yeah so what's interesting is from a defender perspective
if we're going to look at data and make a security decision if we mojibake it we're screwed
but the other thing is if the application is moji baking it that can cause problems so it depends oh
yeah yeah yeah because there were scenarios and maybe get into this um oh i guess that makes sense ones
you're perceiving it as a unicode character but they're perceiving it as ascii you know or yeah okay
that's interesting if they treat each byte as a individual ascii character and they ignore the
leading bit yeah it's just seven bite bit ascii then you can get an ascii character and two who knows
what characters that may be thrown out yeah so when you think about uh control line feed injections
yeah yeah response splitting that's where we saw a crazy bug bounty report i want to say was that a
report on x or on twitter back in the day do you do yeah by file descriptor i think was the guy that
that did it i don't remember the handle but the one i was looking at um it was bug bounty versus
microsoft yeah said how i got six thousand dollars yeah um and we had to deal with this i dealt with
a very similar problem at work when i first sold this yeah all right so wait a second i know from a
defender you're trying to do response you know injection you're trying to do a set cookie
you're sending these crazy chinese characters yeah but when it comes out of the app it's control line
feeds what the heck is happening here now on the one hand it could be a url decoder issue emoji bake
where it's only taking the lowest bite and did it but the other aspect that we researched that's kind
of a related category is what we call unicode truncation that's where even if the url decoder is
multibite aware you decode it you get what the character is how's it going to use that character
is it going to put it in a database is it going to put it in memory and again most of our customers
that they're black boxes but we can tell that they're doing url decoding appropriately but they
took that character and all they're doing is taking the least significant bite treating it as ascii and
it becomes an ascii character so a lot of these control line feed injections when you see those on
cheat sheets this is why they were because the app is just saying nope we're treating this as asking
okay so yeah wait so there's there's truncation there's uh there's and then there's also normalization
and there's things not actually parsing it as multi-byte sequences yep there's um what's the
what's the other one that matias mentioned uh over uh over long yeah yeah that's a subcategory too of
it's a question in the rfc about how you're supposed to do this so if anybody by the time
you're listening to this we're maybe at our talk yeah the real world analogy we have is a picture we
got offline of an amazon box and you open it up there's another amazon box and a bunch of packaging
and you're looking at saying why didn't you just send me that box exactly it's the same thing over
long encoding is needless padding so you have an ascii character it's a single byte yeah you can send it
that way but you can send it in two bytes if you wanted but that other byte all it's doing is saying
i'm a leading byte but i don't have any data that yeah just look at that guy yeah so yeah so the
question is what do you do with that either you can fully normalize it back to ascii which in my
views better or you can say this is bad i'm going to block it so the the one throwback i gave to my
daughter as we were prepping to this and i said when i see this sequence of the overlong i get a
shiver in my and she said why and i said because back in 2001 the nimda worm came out and what the
the nimda worm what's the nimda worm so whoever named this was real crafty yeah it's admin spelled
backwards ah so it's the nimda worm and what it was doing was propagating across microsoft environments
it would exploit systems through a bunch of different protocols in different ways but one was
through iis server they overlong encoded dots and slashes so the security check would fail
because it was overlong but then it would get normalized after the fact yeah and then they
could do command injection and all sorts of stuff so my gosh this stuff's not new yeah and it's still
around it's been around for a while and it will continue to be around because because this unicode
thing is tricky it really is and there's a lot of uh there's you know there's best fit mappings
there's truncation there's uh all sorts of things one of the things that i think is really interesting
also is is what you put in here in the doc is the casing the casing really problems right yeah uh can you
tell us a little bit about some of the gotchas where you know characters may be different you know
and simply running like upper or lower on something exactly transform it uh in these environments
yeah like you were saying like confusables and best fit mappings more people are aware of that over time
yeah this is something too that i think as a developer you're not thinking there's a unicode
component to this but there is now each platform and language depending on how you're doing upper and lower
and you can be doing upper i can't remember full in python i can't remember there's different terms
but when you think from a bug hunter perspective oh here's some input what type of an attack
should i do here right so this is something when you think about like usernames they don't want to
have you log in as like justin@email.com i log in as capital j justin yeah and those are separate no no
they're the same so anytime you think we need to normalize and not have a case sensitive problem
typically they would uppercase or lowercase it and when it does that there's case mapping in unicode
so you can put in a unicode character and this was something that was very uh interesting as well it's
kind of related it was one of the things we talked about uh it was actually on naham con yeah this year
right the ato puny code stuff yep as we were looking at this and we were trying to generalize it and say
well could there be an uppercase casing transform component not in this particular case but in general
maybe but then this dovetails into collations and databases man yeah so as we were researching that
the interesting thing again now is it's unicode combining characters so when you think about you
let's say you have an a character and it's got an accent yeah on it right or umglots or like whatever it might be
depending on the normalization that may happen they may do a decomposition and say okay we understand
what this glyph is but when we store it we're going to store it as ascii a and an accent graph
separately right okay so keep that in mind because with these collations that databases may have
they can have default flags and we were looking at my sql because we actually highlight the ato puny
code examples this is really interesting yeah so what it'll do is you pass that in let's say with
an a with an accent character the default flags in my sql is ai which is accent insensitive so even if
you pass something in that has an accent on it it ignores it so now you just have the base character
no way yeah so my sql itself is doing that conversion yeah it's part of the default so if
you're in it's a part of the default config oh my god yeah and also the other flag is case insensitive
uh so case insensitive accent insensitive now it depends on the collation right however so if
you're bug hunting who knows they may have set their own collation and they may be handling stuff
okay i'm sorry i keep on saying collation i don't have a firm grip of what collation is what is a
collation uh yeah it's 100 disgrunt basically it's you're checking the equivalency of two characters
okay so in the basic sequel statement that we did it's just saying oh select in quotes
the unicode character a with the accent equals in quotes ascii character a okay and it's either
returning a zero or one oh okay okay so are these are these the same character anyone says one oh
they're the same that's not the same and then we show if you change the collation when you do the
select and we changed it to be accent sensitive then it's a zero no no these don't match dude i'm so
hyped for this talk right now this is going to be crazy yeah it was interesting as we were looking
at that because we want to understand wait how did this actually work yeah um yeah so many layers to
it as well right like you know there's that there's the WAF layer there's the application layer there's
the database layer you know there's the browser right like we were talking about we we saw a um
this is only tangentially related but we saw an exploit come across google vrp the other day um
that got got um disclosed uh that was uh taking advantage of um ligatures in the default font used in
your url bar nice so you know there was a google ligature you know to create the google logo in the
font yeah you know we covered it on the pot it was yeah now it's ringing the bell it was freaking beautiful man
it was it was lovely um so there's so many layers to this dude the one last thing because that's what
what we were focusing on initially for combining characters or uh uh critics diacritics yeah um the
other thing which is interesting for bug hunters yeah is think about the sources and sinks again if
there's a sink where your data is right before let's say a greater than character so you have like a
text input yeah it's ending what if you only put the combining character as your first character
and so what we have here as an example there's code this is a dream yeah yes okay okay you can break
context right so what you can do is you send this unicode character which is a reverse full width
soldus or a full width soldus depending on which way you want it to go the one you have linked in
the doc here yes uh you zero three three eight oh my gosh and so then it will combine and become a not
greater than symbol now the key here though is this has to happen server side there needs to be where
the code that's going to be rendered and generated for the web page including your your um like whatever
input text it's wrapped in a normalization and they're adding your character and so is it semi edge
case maybe is it worth a check and tooling it's something to try you know absolutely and and i've
also thought about this many times and i've tried to make it work time and time again in in um scenarios
where you know you need to get rid of something following your thing where i'll put like a um i'll put a
percent sign there right and i'll try to like get an ampersand like like say i need to get rid of a um
a query parameter that is appended after my right specific thing right i'll put like a
a percent sign in there and then it becomes percent ampersand you know the first character of the the
query parameter right right and then that's an invalid you know url decoding so then it freaks
out and sometimes it does weird stuff yeah right right i don't know how to decode yeah exactly so
this is another thing that we can try with that because i've always been like ah there's got to be
something that i can do to affect post you know because obviously the the uh ideal situation is
you've got like a like a hashtag or something like that and you can turn it into the fragment or whatever
right but you don't always have that and so all of the any primitive like this that could potentially
allow you to affect previously hard-coded text that follows your input right so interesting man
breaking context right um frick i love this dude oh my gosh what we were doing and prepping oh my gosh
for the talk and doing the research um is to update tooling right we want to give back and you know
let people use this so um i've worked with james kettle so active scan plus plus for burp users uh we
already have some pull requests in there we're making some more but basically the concept is and
you can adapt this to other tooling yeah yeah is if you're checking for this behavior it's figure out
all right are we talking about confusables do we want to see if there's any normalization do we want
to check your byte trunk like what are we checking for and essentially you get a prefix and a suffix that are
random strings send whatever character you want in between because then the random strings tell you
where it is in the return yep and you're seeing if it changes in the way that you want it if it's
transformed yeah so for example if you want to see if it does any normalization you can send the
unicode kelvin sign it normalizes under all four normalizations so then you know it's doing that's
what i need to know okay unicorn unicorn unicode kelvin so dang it guys do not make a meme in the
freaking discord about unicorn please i said t-shirt dude shut up riot uh the unicode kelvin sign yeah
i think i've seen this before because i think there was a they called it special k yes special k
polygraph exactly that's the one and i believe um the first time i was exposed to this actually was um
yes we hacked bit k researcher um right it showed me some really cool transformations in javascript i think
they used that that k right where you can lowercase it and it goes to like a a normal ascii lowercase k
yeah and i'm like oh my gosh that's crazy that's the same concept so you can check for everything
like we have the other example for unicode truncation we send a chinese character yeah and
if it comes back in between your prefix and suffix as a left curly bracket maybe you want to try some
server-side template injection like there's different checks to do so there should be some tools out by the
time our talk so all right wow definitely interesting stuff there uh gonna be on the lookout for that
talk um i'm glad i get a little insight into it now this is good this is good i got to start adapting
some of this uh this tooling for kaido um yeah very nice man i think i think this last bit about you
the combining characters is really intriguing to me in my brain i can feel it in my brain that i need
to try to figure out what combinations those are there are there um that's in your talk i'm excited
to see it man yeah um let's let's uh we've only got a couple more things here uh you mentioned you
know active scan um we talked a little bit about re-collapse uh before right where uh that's really
helpful for normalization tables and creating those kind of vulnerabilities um trying normalization
vulnerabilities what what um you mentioned sso you mentioned uh you know usernames and stuff like
that what kind of places do you see this most being uh effective for the bug hunters you know
and and i guess yeah it it affects definitely things like cross-site scripting you know normalization
but also you've got critical impact with arbitrary account takeover and if normalization is happening
across sso sign in yeah so i think some of these overlap with the discussion about like
what are good vulnerabilities that lap is great at identifying yeah right so the ato stuff again
in akamai's got a different product to help you account takeovers yeah that's not like an injection
it's a different scenario um most of what i've seen when we get tickets and we have to triage
it's around all of the um well ssrf yeah because enclosed alphanumerics okay those get normalized
there's a unicode or an idna element processing there with the urls that does some normalization
um control line feed injections okay and then cross-site scripting those are the top three those
are the top three that we see not only trying because we see people try all sorts of crazy stuff
with the tools right and now you got all these ai agents it's cheap to test yeah yeah but we have to
weed out that and say what are the things actually show impact that are work yeah exactly and apps do
crazy stuff oh yeah and how they're transforming data so we've seen examples where it's confusables
it's casing haven't seen any combining characters yet keeping my eye out but those are the big ones
and then it's like well okay why is it happening you know that's usually part of our triage we have to
figure out what is going on access xss crlf yeah ssrf ssrf and then we've got those sort of normalization
attacks on sso and usernames uh yeah yeah yeah yeah if it's normalizing all right well we'll uh we'll
give it a shot we'll see what we can find i definitely think the combining characters research that
you've done and especially the i mean the the collation stuff for sure but the um the combining
character stuff definitely has a lot of potential i think that will result in some bugs i got to get some of
those uh you know into my um normal testing routine exactly you know get them in your tooling yeah um
the last thing that we had really on the list here is csps um and i think you have been a very
interesting little piece here about how csps can sometimes be implemented at the the waft level right
you know um can you talk about the pros and cons of implementing csp there and what bug hunters need to
know about that yeah um whether it's a quote-unquote laugh or just something that's an
intermediary yeah upstream from the app right yeah um some customers find that attractive because
maybe not every app stack they have that can quickly oh you're doing csp like that's built into some
apps right it's easy to do other ones it's not and you want to have a centralized place to have your policies
so from an architecture perspective it makes sense for me when i work i keep hitting this thing
when i work with customers who want to do this it's a question of what are you trying to achieve
with csp right what order do you implement these in and then where is it where you probably want to
do that at what we call origin that's the customer application yeah um so anytime you're getting into we
want to nonce data to say obviously oh no this is secure or hashing or anything like that that really
should be done at origin yeah but other stuff is easy and fine you can push that where we say downstream
to us and then we'll send it out to the client so there's advantages depending what they want to do
with the policy where this gets interesting is if you have that intermediary and it's auto noncing data
originating from the app right in in line cross-site scripting um so yeah i i ran into this with testing
with some other third-party security products that were doing this yeah as a customer was evaluating
and i kind of pointed this out because i was able to do reflected xss and it auto nonced it for me and
yeah i don't think this is the best idea that's very interesting yes stored xss reflected xss i guess
really what that auto noncing feature would be intended to stop is is dom xss right because that's
the only scenario where that's really going to become handy but yeah the the only kind of reference
i will make here again i'm name dropping that uh xss doctor yeah and he's doing all my boy exactly
my boy xs doctor so we were chatting on discord a little bit and this was coming up and we were just
going over stuff and he had made a comment about in general like csp ways to bypass it and generally
saying oh like if i see a not it's like is it worth my time to try and do because they're announcing
it yeah so i just made that comment i said just because you see a knots test yeah it may be worth
now are they in this scenario maybe not but they might be and then the nonce does not matter it'll auto
not so it's something again from a tooling perspective maybe you could test a few things and see
yeah i wouldn't just give up on that yeah because it may just be auto noncing it it might be considering
it apart or there could be some like i don't even know if it's middleware you know something you know
back end back side where i don't know you know that that after everything's done it's going back
through and and announcing it uh so there's lots of ways that that attackers input could get nonced in
those sort of situations yep wow very interesting stuff and then and then um you also you know one of the
things that uh you kind of have access to with akamai is the perspective of looking at these csp violation
reports yeah um what kind of juicy stuff have you found in those and and uh i always thought that
that's a really cool vector because if you were able even as an attacker to inject into that you know
csp reporting environment you can trigger a csp violation right and then you know get data out that way
so there's lots of cool tricks yeah um right so we talked about the scenario if they wanted akamai to
add the csp policies which we can yeah then if you want to do any sort of reporting to beaconing right
yeah you can send that wherever you want it doesn't have to be back to us or whatever but um some
customers opt to have it come through us and they can have us actually act as like a csp report endpoint
and then they can actually see stuff interesting or it goes all the way through but with that we
had to talk with them and say okay well then when that's coming through you don't want to block it
like just come on through and then they have a reporting that's back behind us right so it's an
architectural question now what's interesting what you were just saying is i can look at all sorts of
csp reports and if you're familiar with what those reports look like in the json different uh you know
policy things and so i'm interested in of course like samples and i said report sample uh what was the
blocked uri there's a few things i go and look at and there's interesting stuff that you can see that
people are trying to beacon or what are they trying a new technique whatever it might be well what's also
funny those exactly what you just said all this tooling will take anything and every input and
whatever and inject everywhere it's inject everything and so i'll be looking at something
that oh what was the original csp policy cross-site scripting tag they're just they're trying to
anything you know what i mean because oh my gosh maybe it'll pop somewhere so that's part of weeding out
it's like that's bogus that's just an attacker yeah putzing around with the report json coming back so
it's noise yeah well sometimes sometimes you know those logs can end up i mean we talked about a
blind xss scenario before those those can go into like janky back-end systems where they process it and
that's why blind is so crazy yeah exactly exactly yeah um so there's always that that impact there as
well very very interesting one one thing you said before that it didn't have on the list but i do want
to circle uh circle back to is um one of the first sort of interactions that i had with a waaf as a as a
hunter was trying to bypass a waaf uh via locating the origin server um right how often do you see that
misconfiguration in in clients you know like where they're not just white listing communication with akamai
right or something changes is that and i guess i don't know my question that i want to ask is like
how can i find the freaking origin server but i don't know if you're going to be able to give me much
with that uh not really mainly i'll plead that that's not my area okay that's a platform okay okay
all right get off the hook on that one yeah um that it is in a sense now it's supposed to be a typical
onboarding yeah that you talk with the customer because we have a lot of customers that are only on
performance yeah they want us as a cdn yeah reminding it so okay right yeah we don't even think about that
as hackers you know because we're like oh my waaf but it's you know originally it was a cdn right
serves a purpose yeah makes everything faster so yeah yeah but security side of the house that's a
discussion when there's onboarding and to say look if you don't want people to reach your origin
and get around the edge network then you have to figure out how to configure that um so they know
about it now the question is okay why wasn't it implemented um sometimes it's hard you know you
have to configure network firewalls to figure out how to talk with the edge systems and make sure
that they're always set up properly right um and sometimes i guess that that doesn't happen or
things change there's also scenarios where typically the edge network to make everything
faster it knows where servers are that are geographically close to you and all of that so
you know i again i don't work on that side of the operations and working with customers on
configuring but if you only configured it to work with certain akamai servers because they're in
your region but then somebody goes through a different one and you're just not restricting
i don't know um yeah but yeah being able to bypass that um it's an issue so that's why we tell
customers no no if you want this we call it site shield you got to configure site shield to say we
only talk you know with akamai directly yeah the other scenario there is you were thinking typically
oh i'm a hacker i'm doing web application attacks um there's also the issue of denial of service yeah
that if they know the origin and go directly to it now in this case
because if they find an ip they can still slam it oh yeah from an application attacker yeah you
can't actually get in to do what you wanted but if they're just wanting to flood they can do that
anyway so again there's different ddos scenarios where we can front end and we have a whole different
system for doing that but um yeah but that's been an issue with any cdnwap i've seen tools out there
with like cloudflare trying to find if you can find the original source ip before they onboard it that's
the issue yeah exactly so and and that's often in the dns history you know you can go back and look
before they onboarded their waft you know you can say oh where was that ip oh it's still there yeah
yeah exactly exactly um yeah uh okay i i said last thing but i did come up with one more thing
um one of the you know by nature of these these wafts it's important that it's necessary that you have
to be able to have some routes that you hit that return data from the waft rather than from the actual
origin you know something to do like your bot check and stuff like that um that has become a very
interesting attack surface uh for uh attackers and i've spent a good amount of time looking at
um you know the slash c cdn cgi uh endpoints and stuff like that right okay um
i guess what what is your your and this once again this might be a product question rather than
you know the researcher side which is kind of where you're at right but um running a bug bounty
program yourself right you know that i imagine is very high value attack surface to you and it is uh
what would it be possible maybe for us to get some additional introspection into what those
endpoints are exposed on every on every host oh yeah good question um well it is important one thing
that you just mentioned that uh akamai does have a bug bounty program yeah right now it's scoped just
for the platform yeah but also linode had a long yeah excellent program yeah to them yeah so that's
within scope of what we're doing as well um so i don't know that's a good question to fit it's a
scoping question yeah right we set up also a sandboxed environment that has different origin setups with
different stacks and also from more from the protocol perspective that we want to have uh nginx apache node.js
but we have a whole system set up where you can test and stuff echoes back and so you can see what's
happening that's interesting um a a a hat tip uh to james kettle who's doing his his research you know
i we talked i triaged his bone he found that he's talking about a black guy yeah um so we have an area
set up for this which will help to identify these types of situations and gives you back some debugging
information to see exactly what made it to origin how did it change how's it coming back um so it's not
full-blown it is more of a product question on all these different things that may potentially have
problems but we're looking to expand the scope yeah um so the waaf currently is not in scope like like
if we find vulnerabilities um let's say on those endpoints that need to be exposed right uh you know
that are under a customer's domain but are actually you know akamai code uh those are currently not in
scope correct that's okay it's a product question now yeah i am working to get it within scope yeah
part of the question is okay what scope do you put around laugh right um yeah because there are some
programs that'll just be like all right here's 25 dollars per right you know laugh bypass high volume
low value yeah uh we don't not really go in that direction we don't really want to get in that game
because when yeah part of when you think about the day-to-day business of laugh and yes a bit of
whack-a-mole with some of the detections that's day-to-day business that's not something we deem
as a like evasion and some of this is internal terminology and i'm not sure maybe this is something
that i just use but uh the way i look at these are the day-to-day stuff like that or oh that's an
interesting cross-state scripting vector okay we need to catch that that's a bypass evasion is something
deeper in the platform protocol processing the way i say it is if my team can't fix it it's an evasion
because we have to get with engineers ah whole different scope and timelines and so we don't want
to get into the bounties for bypass that's maybe we'll do some specials i've seen that before like
hey for the next whatever here send us give us cool techniques yeah but right now it's it's focusing
more on on lower level kind of protocol bypassing kinds yeah that's that's fun research though it's a
good research target so yeah um glad you guys are running a program on that um one other thing i'll
mention actually this is going to come out i guess after we're in vegas um the current state of the
program right we had a private for a while now it's not private it's on hacker one you can find our page
um but it was invite for a while but now anybody who kind of asks you haven't turned anybody away
like if you say hey can i come to your program we'll just let you in and then nice there's a
little different information where it gives you about our sandbox and you do all that stuff so
we are right on the fence to being full-blown public public yeah we're working our way over that fence
um but anyways i plan when i'm in vegas talking with people to let them know yeah um so if you're
talking with people and they say aka mike say oh you can ask to join the program they can join heck
yeah dude i'm excited for that i think that'll be great i think it's really important for for these
types of software to have you know bug bounty programs and i know a public program is a big step
um yeah and you got to deal with a lot of uh you know reported blocks and stuff like that but
yeah it's a bandwidth issue yeah absolutely man well uh whenever you guys go public let me
know i i i'll give you a shout out i owe you one for for coming on the pod and for showing me a good
time up here today absolutely pleasure dude thank you so much man appreciate it oh hold on yeah we
got it for the end of the for the end of the episode let me get the uh hold on uh all right
well we'll call it a wrap there oh you guys can see um here we go this is going to be the thumbnail
right here yeah three two one nice very good all right thanks man great episode and that's a wrap on
this episode of critical thinking thanks so much for watching to the end y'all if you want more critical
thinking content uh or if you want to support the show head over to ctbb.show discord you can hop in
the community there's lots of great high-level hacking discussion happening there on top of master
classes hack alongs exclusive content and a full-time hunters guild if you're a full-time hunter it's a
great time trust me all right i'll see you there